cette image va rester longtemps dans les
consciences elle reflète à elle seule
les décennies de racisme et de violence
aux états unis contre la population
noire et les victimes sont nombreuses
leurs visages tristement devenus
célèbres sont aujourd'hui les symboles
du mouvement black live matheuse car les
statistiques font peur un jeune homme
noir à cinq fois plus de chances de se
faire arrêter qu'un jeune homme blanc et
deux fois plus de chances plus vertueux
avants john floyd en février c'était à
mode abri 25 ans et non armés il se fait
tuer par un policier à la retraite et
son fils alors qu'il faisait son jogging
trois mois plus tard les deux hommes
sont inculpés la vidéo de l'attak avait
été rendue publique en mars dernier
biyouna trailer une ambulancière de 26
ans abattue en pleine nuit par des
policiers du kentucky
alors qu'elle dormait chez elle
l'affairé devant les tribunaux
chaque fois ce sont des familles
éplorées des vie basculer à jamais
monroe baisse prévisible
laissez moi tranquille disait reagan aux
policiers en juillet 2014
il était soupçonné de vendre des
cigarettes illégalement il est alors
plaqué au sol je ne peux pas respirer
disait-il comme jauge floyd il meurt
quelques heures plus tard d'un malaise
cardiaque
le policier daniel pantaleo n'a pas été
inculpé un mois plus tard michael brown
18 ans mon armée et sans casier
judiciaire et a battu par six coups de
feu du policier darron gibson
le policier ne sera pas inculpé la ville
de fuck the sun s'enflamme alors un an
plus tard walter scott est arrêté car un
de ses feux arrière ne fonctionne pas il
tente de s'enfuir
il est abattu à bout portant le policier
condamné chaque mort à son slogan and
that don't shoot mains en l'air ne
tirait pas en hommage à michael braun
skateurs pour travel martin il avait 17
ans il était juste aller chercher des
bonbons dépanneur en portant un concours
au un résident la tuer car il le
trouvait suspect et puis à cannes brise
pour et rigolent et josh floyd
pour beaucoup il n'y a pas plus de
violences qu'avant la différence c'est
qu'elles sont filmées la mort de john
floyd bouleverse toute l'amérique et sa
conscience de miami à new york au
missouri
ces policiers se sont mis à genoux
d'autres ont fraternisé avec les
manifestants un signe d'espoir pour du
changement mais c'est un contraste avec
le discours du président américain qui
lui était loin d'être rassembleur ici
elle évoque d'ailleurs 10 radio canada
montréal